over the Second Amendment heating up
again in the wake of two mass shootings
in California and a nationwide crime
crisis Governor Gavin Newsom thinks the
solution is to ban guns
I mean the second amendment is becoming
a suicide pact but there's many people
in this country
and our lawful government yeah I have
great respect I have no ideological
opposition to someone reasonably and
responsibly earning firearms and getting
background checks and being trained how
did he get a gun that's illegal in the
state exactly we'll figure it out that's
going to happen
you've got to enforce laws Things fall
through the cracks but it doesn't mean
you give up and despite the push for a
Crackdown on Firearms California has
some of the strictest gun control laws
in the entire nation and other blue
areas that are tough on guns are not
seeing reduced crime rates a new study
shows democrat-run cities like Baltimore
Chicago New York and La have some of the
highest homicide rates and a lot of
those deaths are gun related let's go to
our favorite
native Californian oh Greg Gutfeld what
do you think well first of all I I don't
trust anybody if on upon gun control if
they don't know the terms
you know what I mean
I do it's a call back uh uh and and also
those who refuse the agency of the
criminal it's like it's always the gun
that's doing the killing as if it's up
on two little legs running on the street
shooting people I don't trust anybody
who cannot tell the difference between a
thug with a gun and a shopkeeper with a
gun that's a huge moral and intellectual
flaw in any argument why is there no
Second Amendment phobia right you're
critical of anything on the left it's a
phobia you know a radical Islam
islamophobia if you're critical of
obesity that's what is that fat phobic
if you think gender affirmation
surgeries are bad that's transphobic we
have a problem with defensophobia right
people who fear lawful gun owners and
besmirched them and try to take their
rights away rather than face the real
problem which are the thugs with the
guns
one of the things that was kind of
absurd about this is that the Democrats
initially called for an immediate
assault weapons ban but the California
shooter the first one of them used a
handgun to do his killing yeah it was
like a nine millimeter mach 10 kind of
like a poor man zuzi I guess it had an
extended clip 30 rounds I don't know if
it was modified the shoot automatic but
you see those things in like a Steven
Seagal movie from the 80s I mean this
isn't real it's not even an assault
weapon under their definition of an
assault weapon
and he better watch his mouth if he
wants to run for president you can't say
the Second Amendment is a suicide pact
if he was here I would have had him run
that analogy by me because that is such
an inflammatory statement and you're
right he doesn't know how to talk about
it because I don't think he's ever shot
a weapon I Googled Gavin knew some
hunting you cannot find a photo of Gavin
Newsom holding a gun now Democrats it's
Kerry it's Gore if it's Clinton Barack
Obama remember the photo shoot with him
I mean even even Joe Biden talks about I
have shotguns
you have to at least go to the range
once to just be able to talk about it to
have that experience as an American to
respect the Second Amendment because if
you don't respect the Second Amendment
you don't respect the founders our
rights the Pioneers the police you have
to have that experience and I don't
think he has that experience and that's
why he's so reckless with his language
and he never talks about crime he only
talks about mass shootings there's
homicides all the time there's 2 000
homicides a year in California doesn't
talk about those only talks about mass
shootings because he's soft on crime and
he's tough on guns because it's easier
to be tough on guns hard because it
takes commitment to be tough on crime
Harold what about some creative thinking
about going after the problem of the gun
violence rather than just the gun I mean
it's it's as if they just double down on
the laws that they already have as we
pointed out a lot of these cities have
very strict gun laws and as Nora
O'Donnell as the governor and he says
yeah we don't know how he got the
illegal gun so I think I think you're
right the premise of your question is
the gun laws we have in a lot of these
states in a lot of these cities are not
achieving the amen that we want or the
end that I think all of us want and you
may assign it just to Democrats but I
don't think anyone wants mass shootings
I don't think anyone wants the kind of
violence we see in communities the
cities that you put up and for that
matter other cities including our home
City here in New York so if you have to
push the reset button and start over we
should I would ask everybody around the
table and for that matter those who
first off we agree we don't want mass
shootings and we want to try to
eliminate gun violence in in communities
where where kids are getting shot and
drive-bys are happening so how do we do
that we need more police officers most
police organizations support gun control
laws or some support stricter gun
control laws we have including big
police Chiefs all across the country
because they have to deal with it
firsthand but I'm a second amendment guy
and I believe that I don't think that
anyone I would not have used the word
suicide pact but I understand his
passion so I think everybody should take
a step back and I would encourage
Congressman Comer the chair of the
oversight committee this might be some
area to exercise some oversight in to
tell mayor look your plans aren't
working your laws are not working your
Governor your laws are not working let's
push the reset button I want to help you
figure out how we reduce uh these these
killings in these mass shootings and
hopefully we can come to some agreement
because what we have now isn't working
and judge is there something about not
Prosecuting the laws that are on the
books
that's exactly the issue everybody's
sitting here talking about the laws if
the laws aren't enforced there's not
going to be an end to Crime whether it's
Petty Lara City or whether it's murder
or homicide by a handgun or buy an Uzi
you know or some kind of uh some kind of
machine gun one of the things you said
Harold was most police Chiefs support
some kind of gun control I'm not sure
that's the case is but you can go right
to Illinois where I think it was
pritzker who said that uh he wanted some
kind of limit and the sheriff's all came
out and they said we're not going to
make we're not going to make arrests in
these cases but let me just say that it
is an issue of enforcement now when he
gets up there and he says I have great
respect for gun owners he's talking out
of both sides of his mouth when he says
it's a suicide pact meaning I'm going to
be killed because I have guns and
somebody else who has guns is going to
be killed I mean that is not great
respect for a gun owner or for the
Second Amendment and in addition to that
you know it's when he says I don't know
where the gun came from but we'll find
out well I'm not sure you're going to
find out Governor because you really
don't do a lot on the gun trafficking
The Sting operations the enforcement and
the ultimate punishment you arrest
people in your state with guns and then
you let them go and then they get
another gun and you wonder why there's
everybody's got a gun and it's killing
everyone there is no effective
consequence if you have a gun and that
is the problem so you can blame that gun
as Greg says on two little legs it runs
out and decides it's going to kill
people and I I would venture a guess
because 30 years in law enforcement as a
D.A I saw one homicide in the county of
a million people with a legal gun we're
talking illegal guns we are not talking
about legal gun owners getting involved
in these in these contests and the
shooting contests and I'm sure the guy
who shot and killed in those mass
shootings didn't have a legal gun so
that's our problem you give me the U.S
attorney's statistics for California if
I could get my hands on them and I'll
show you why they've got a gun problem
just for just perfect the national
States police organizations they support
an assault weapons ban so I'm not saying
they support all of it but they support
stricter gun that's all I'm saying yeah
and there's D.A a lot of stayed in 93
and then we saw it didn't make a
difference
interesting and that's an amazing
statistic one out of 30 years incredible
all right hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now